there was a tweet yesterday from richard
henania he's a progressive think tank
president he tweeted out quote
you can't screen for down syndrome
before about 10 weeks and something like
80 of down syndrome fetuses are aborted
if red states ban abortion we would see
a world where they have five times as
many children with down syndrome and
similar numbers for other disabilities
the horror the horror that
people with disabilities might be
permitted to live could you imagine ugh
we'd have to look at them we'd have to
oh god we might even have to talk to
them could you imagine ugh they wouldn't
all be perfect you know like we are
we're so perfect not like them they're
defective they're ugh
yucky huh
he goes on could be outliers in the
whole developed world
there are already negative stereotypes
of americans in these states huh you get
it ha they're all they're all retards
those [ __ ] republicans down in the
southern states imagine if we had real
retards running around gosh that'd be
terrible got to keep killing them
through abortion one can imagine he
writes
it getting much more extreme what if
they also ban genetic engineering and
embryo selection as we obviously should
use psycho
while other places go ahead oh god could
you imagine
we wouldn't we wouldn't all just be
perfect we wouldn't all just be perfect
perfect like richard is doesn't he seem
perfect to you
oh a wonderful specimen
mentally physically and spiritually
right
i don't think so my friend spencer
clavin made this point yesterday we're
we are rightly disgusted by i mean this
is sick psycho stuff
this is the norm okay this is the norm
richard hinania is the norm eugenics is
the norm
trying to kill off the weak trying to
kill off people who might have some more
visible problems than others that's the
norm in human society child sacrifice is
the norm in human society
then
you have
in the old testament you see in in
judaism a turn away from human sacrifice
a taking of the side of the victim
rather than of the community that tries
to sacrifice the victim and then you see
the fullness of this in christianity
which says no
no we're not doing that and the reason
that we in the west have had a problem
with eugenics where every other country
on earth every other culture on earth
has not
every other culture on earth
has and in many cases continues to
practice child sacrifice and we
increasingly are practicing child
sacrifice the only thing that has
distinguished us is
that we are a christian civilization
or at least we were now it would appear
that we are not exactly defined by
christianity expect more child sacrifice
expect more psychos like henania and
biden and all the rest of them i'm so
glad that you liked that clip if you
wouldn't mind doing me a little favor
one
leave me a comment just let me know what
you thought michael good hair michael i
like that jacket two pull out your phone
i'll do it myself pull out your phone
right now right now what else are you
doing you're just scrolling you're not
doing it pull out your phone
go to the podcast app
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play whatever you use type in the
michael knowles show
subscribe just click subscribe
you're good maybe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you